شكراً جزيلاً لك على مدى أسابيع
تنافس الرئيس ترامب مع مسؤولي الصحة
بشأن عقار هيدروكسي كلوروكين
لمحاربة فيروس كورونا ، يبدو أن الرئيس
معجب كبير بما يجب أن تخسره
سأقوله للحصول على ما يجب أن تخسره ،
أعتبره حقًا  أعتقد أنهم يجب أن
يأخذوها لكن أفضل طبيب للأمراض المعدية في البلاد
يقول إننا بحاجة إلى دراستها
قبل أن نعرف ما إذا كانت تعمل أم لا ، لا
توجد علاجات آمنة وفعالة
لفيروس كورونا اليوم
نتوقع أن نحصل على تلميح حول ما إذا كان
هيدروكسي كلوروكين قادرًا على ذلك.  المساعدة في علاج
مرضى فيروس كورونا
من المتوقع ظهور النتائج الأولية من أول
دراسة واسعة النطاق للدواء في
مرضى فيروس كورونا بتمويل من ولاية
نيويورك ، وهي تشمل مئات
المرضى في المستشفى
وأجرتها جامعة ألباني نيويورك
وليس فقط إحراز تقدم  بشأن التحقيق في
العلاجات المحتملة لفيروس كورونا
ولكن عند الاختبار أيضًا ، أعلن الحاكم أندرو
كومو يوم الأحد أن
ولايته ستجري  أكبر مسح للأجسام المضادة
في الدولة إذا كان لدى شخص ما
أجسام مضادة لـ kovat 19 ، فهذا يعني
أنه مصاب وقد يكون الآن محصنًا ،
سنجري آلاف اختبارات الأجسام المضادة
خلال الأسبوع المقبل في جميع أنحاء
الولاية لإعطائنا لقطة حقيقية
لخط أساس حقيقي لـ  يأمل خبراء
الصحة العامة في الصحة العامة
في إجراء
اختبارات الأجسام المضادة على نطاق واسع في نهاية المطاف في جميع أنحاء
البلاد إذا كان عدد كافٍ من الأشخاص محصنين ، فمن
المحتمل أن تبدأ البلاد في
الانفتاح مرة أخرى بأمان ،
رئيس الجمعية الطبية الأمريكية د.  باتريس هاريس
وكبير المراسلين الطبيين لشبكة CNN د.  سانجاي
جوبتا د.  اسمح لي هاريس أن أقرأ لك ما قاله
مدير مركز السيطرة على الأمراض للتو لصحيفة
واشنطن بوست ، هناك
احتمال أن هجوم
الفيروس على أمتنا في الشتاء المقبل سيكون في
الواقع أكثر صعوبة من ذلك
الذي مررنا به للتو
، يضيف وعندما '  لقد قلنا هذا
للآخرين ، إنهم نوعًا ما أعادوا رؤوسهم إلى الوراء
، فهم لا يفهمون ما أعنيه
بوضوح د.  هاريس أنت تفهم
ما يعنيه
أنني أفعل الذئب وهذه
معلومات مهمة قادمة من د.  ريدفيلد
أعتقد أن الأطباء قلقون
بشأن الموجة الثانية وبالتأكيد
علمنا أنه إذا كان هذا الفيروس يعمل مثل فيروسات أخرى ،
فقد نشهد عودة ظهوره في
الخريف ولكن يجب أن أخبرك أنني
قلق أيضًا بشأن موجة ثانية قادمة
قريبًا  أنا قلق حقًا بشأن تلك
الولايات التي تخفف من بعض هذه
اللوائح الخاصة بالبقاء في المنزل في وقت سابق
ويمكن أن نحصل على موجة ثانية حتى
قبل الخريف المقلق للغاية
وأنت تتحدث عن جورجيا حيث
تعيش هناك أيضًا حيث د.  يعيش سانجاي جوبتا
وأريد الوصول إلى ذلك في
لحظة سانجاي لكن القلق هو ما
يحدث عندما يكون فيروس كورونا
وفقًا للدكتور.  يتزامن Redfield مع
اندلاع موسم الأنفلونزا هنا في
الولايات المتحدة ، فكيف نستخدم هذه
الأشهر القليلة القادمة لإعداد لا سمح الله
لهذا الاحتمال جيدًا من بعض النواحي ،
إنها نفس الأشياء التي
كنا نتحدث عنها في
الأشهر القليلة الماضية.  أنت تعلم أننا تحدثنا عن
التأكد من أن المستشفيات مهيأة بشكل كاف
من حيث الأسرة
والسعة الاستيعابية وآلات التنفس المستحيلة
عندما يتعين عليك التأكد من أن
لدينا ما يكفي من معدات الحماية الشخصية
أعتقد أن هناك شيئين يمكن
أن يقوم بهما د.  كان ريدفيلد
يشير حقًا وقد قال هذا النوع
من الأشياء قبل أن أعتقد أنه قد أزال
إحساسًا جديدًا بالإلحاح إذا
تعلم الناس المزيد عن فيروس كورونا
ولكن الثابت هو أن الفيروس
لا يزال موجودًا.
معد جدا مثل د.  قالت هاريس إن هذا هو السبب في
أنها وكثير من الأشخاص الآخرين
قلقون بشأن عودة الظهور في وقت أقرب
ولكن هذه المرة حول فيروس كورونا
الذي تعرف أن تفشي المرض في الولايات المتحدة
جاء نوعًا ما حيث بدأ موسم الأنفلونزا
في التلاشي إذا حدث في نفس الوقت
الوقت الذي يتطلبه موسم الأنفلونزا وموسم الأنفلونزا في
كثير من الأحيان أن تعرف أن الكثير من
المرضى ينتهي بهم الأمر بالذهاب إلى
المستشفى وتحتاج إلى الكثير من هذه
الموارد نفسها التي قد تحتاجها
لتفشي فيروس كورونا في هذا البلد ، لذا
فإن هذين الأمرين سيكونان متطابقين
للقلق ، وكلاهما يعرفهما
يجعلنا نشعر حقًا بالحاجة إلى كل
هذه الأشياء نفسها ، مثل اختبار
أجهزة التنفس الصناعي ، وأسرة المستشفى ،
ومعالجي الجهاز التنفسي ، كل هذه الأشياء
مرة أخرى ، وهل لدينا ما يكفي في الوقت الحالي ،
نشعر نوعًا ما وكأننا مررنا
بهذا الأمر  قد تتضاءل الأرقام خلال
الصيف ، ولكن إذا ظهرت مرة أخرى في
الخريف ، يجب أن نكون مستعدين
[موسيقى
] لنعرف أنها كانت ستحبها ، فالحب الذي يتمتع به أحد
الوالدين لطفلهما يكون ثمينًا.
rnal وعندما استعادوا
هذا الحب ، ما هو شعور عظيم
هو أنه يمكنك رؤية حب
سكايلر لأمها وأبيها من خلال
ابتسامتها الجميلة وعناقها المرتبط بها
كانت روحًا جميلة كانت
ودودة كانت تحبها كانت تهتم بها
مضحك مجرد
طفل يبلغ من العمر خمس سنوات أن يخسر طفلاً في
سن الخامسة ليس عادلاً أبدًا
وتعقيدات من كوبان 19 كيف على
الأرض أن تلف رأسك قلبك
حول هذا تصوير مؤلم
لا أفعله.  لا أريد أن توفيت أي عائلة أخرى
سكايلر في مستشفى بومونت رويال أوك
بعد أن أمضت أسبوعين على جهاز
التنفس الصناعي
أثبتت سكايلر
إصابتها بفيروس كورونا الشهر الماضي ولم يمض وقت طويل على
إصابتها بنوع نادر من التهاب السحايا
وتورم في الدماغ  هذا الفيروس لا
يهتم بعمرك ، وما
هي جنسيتك ، وما التفضيل السياسي
لديك ، فهو خطير
وسيصيب والدي سكايلر اللذين يعملان كلاهما
كأول مستجيبين في ديترويت م.  لقد واجه ضابط شرطة
أبي رجل إطفاء
مواقف صعبة لتغيير الحياة ولكن لم يكن هناك شيء يمكن
أن يهيئهما لفقدان
طفلتهما ، ماتت ابنتنا حتى نتمكن
من إخبار العالم حقًا أن طفلًا في
الخامسة من عمره يمكنه تغيير العالم
نحن فقط نريد إيصال رسالتنا
هنا ، لقد كانت فتاة صغيرة جميلة
عاشت حياتها لمدة خمس سنوات
كنت تعلم أنها عاشت حياة رائعة
في تلك السنوات الخمس
التي تتعلم فيها
أن اختبارات فيروس كورونا السريع  ادعى الرئيس
أن لعبة كرة جديدة تمامًا يمكن أن
تعطي نتائج غير دقيقة ، ما الذي يمكنك
إخبارنا به ، نعم ، هذا هو أن
آلة نقطة الرعاية الصغيرة دانيال
أشار للتو إلى ذلك يخبرك
على الفور ما إذا كان
لديك أم لا أو على الفور تقريبًا.  كوفات
أم لا ، أجرت كليفلاند كلينك بعض الاختبارات
عليها باستخدام هذه العملية حيث تقوم
بالفعل بأخذ مسحة ووضعها في
قنينة ثم اختبارها ووجدت أن
معدل الدقة فيها 15٪.
فشل Rcent في الكشف عن الفيروس المشفر
غير المقبول ، قام Abbot على الفور
بإخطار إدارة الغذاء والدواء وجميع عملائه
بما في ذلك البيت الأبيض
الذي يستخدم هذا الجهاز وأخبرهم
أنه لم يعد بإمكانهم أو لا ينبغي عليهم
استخدام هذا الجهاز في ظل
ظروف معينة سوى استخدامه  فقط على
وجه التحديد عند نقطة الرعاية حيث
تأخذ عينة من الأنف مباشرة
إلى الجهاز ، لذا فهي تسلط الضوء فقط على
المشكلات التي تواجهك عندما تسرع في إجراء
بعض هذه الاختبارات التي تخرج
دون كل العناية الواجبة
وبدون كل القواعد واللوائح
بعد متابعتك ، عليك أن
تتعلم وأنت تتقدم على طول حيث يمكن ارتكاب الأخطاء ،
لذلك آمل أن الآلة التي أصبحت
الآن متأكدًا من فئة 700000 اختبار تم
إجراؤها بالفعل ، فقد حصلت الآن على بعض
الإرشادات الجديدة حول كيفية استخدامها.
الوقت الصعب بالنسبة لنا
مع هذا الفيروس التاجي ، نحن نعمل
بلا توقف على مدار الساعة طوال أيام الأسبوع ، اسمي كيلي موريس
، أنا ممرضة الوقاية من العدوى هنا
في مستشفى MedStar harbor.  لدي
ميكروبات وكائنات حية تعيش على
أجسامنا والتي لا تسبب ضررًا في العادة ،
ولكن إذا نقص المناعة
عندها يمكن أن تغزو وتسبب
العدوى ، فغسل اليدين هو
سلاح أقوى بكثير ضد الجراثيم مما
يدرك الكثير منا أن  إن فيروس أه الحالي هو
فيروس تنفسي ينتشر بسهولة هذه
الجزيئات عندما نتحدث عندما نعطس
أسبوعًا واحدًا متناثرة في الهواء
ونهبط على أشياء يمكننا بعد ذلك
التقاطها وعندما نلمس وجهنا جيدًا
إذا لمسنا فمنا إذا  لمس
أنفنا يمكنهم الدخول إلينا ، فكر
في فيروس كورونا يشبه إلى حد كبير كرة مليئة
بالمعلومات الجينية التي تحيط
به بالبروتينات والدهون ، تعمل الدهون
مثل الغراء الذي يجمعها معًا عندما
تغسل يديك ، والصابون يكسر هذه
القشرة الدهنية  والبروتينات عندما
تتكسر القشرة ، يموت الفيروس ،
وهنا بعض الأشياء التي تريد أن
تتذكرها عندما
تغسل يديك بشكل صحيح دافئة أو باردة ، لا يهم
تأكد من تبليل يدك  أضف هذا
الصابون وتريد أن تغسل على الأقل لمدة
15 إلى 20 ثانية ، ضع بعض الاحتكاك الذي
نريده لإزالة كل تلك الجراثيم ، ولا
تنسى ما بين أصابعك
وحول كل سرير ظفر ظهر
يديك وجزء سفلي من
يمكن لغسل راحة اليد هو الطريقة
الأولى التي يمكننا من خلالها قتل فيروس كورونا
الآن نريد التخلص من كل تلك الجراثيم
في الحلم وتجفيف يديك ،
نحتاج إلى حماية كل شخص أحباؤنا
والدينا وأطفالنا
وأجدادنا وكذلك أنفسنا